字幕: Takahiro Shimpo
校正: Asami HATANO
(音楽)
(拍手)
ありがとうございます
初めまして
BMX Flatland
ワールドチャンピオン 内野 洋平です
宜しくお願いします
(拍手)
まず BMX Flatland
今 見てもらってようにですね
知らない方が
たくさんいるんではないかと思います
簡単に説明すると
この小さい自転車で
クルクル回ったりとか
跳んだりとか
フィギュアスケートのような
似ている競技だとよく言われます
本当にルールとかも
すごく似ていて
技術点
芸術点
完成度
難易度
ジャッジとかもですね
そういう審判の得点で
優勝とかが決まる
そういう競技です
で 僕がなぜ
この競技に出会ったかと言うと
高校生の時にクラスメイト９人で
なにか一つのことをしよう
という話になりまして
スケートボードが一番モテる
と 雑誌で書いてありました
当時 高校生だった僕たちは
その雑誌の文章を鵜呑みにしまして
９人でスケートボードを
やろうと決めたんですけども
その中の１人が
神戸のメリケンパークという場所で
スケートボードの大会があるらしいと
で 僕たちは
じゃあそこに行って
どこで買えばいいのか
どういう風に練習したらいいのか
聞こうと
みんなで向かいました
すると メリケンパークに
着いたときにですね
その情報源が間違ってまして
(笑)
BMX の大会だったと
なんとも軽い動機でですね
始めてしまいまして
まあ でも僕たちは全員一致で
「これでも モテるんじゃないか」と
(笑)
ということでBMX を始めました
今 聞いていただいた通り
始めたきっかけは
そういう些細な
出会いだったんですけども
まさか 今日こういう場所で
喋ってるとは
高校生の時の僕は
全く想像がつかなかったと思います
で ですね そこから
僕のエクストリーム人生の
始まりだったわけですけども
よくインタビューで聞かれます
「そんだけBMX を続けている
魅力って何ですか」と
僕は魅力は
たくさんあると思っていますけど
そん中の一つとして
技を創れる楽しみ
やはりここだな と
野球でですね
昔 むかーし 昔を辿っていくと
ストレートのボールしか
なかった時にですね
カーブを発明した人がいる
スライダーを発明した人がいる
シンカーを発明した人がいる
そういう歴史に名を
刻んできた人たちに
なれるんですね
BMX って歴史がまだ
40年ぐらいなんで
そんなにまあ深くもなく
もっともっと
未開拓な技がたくさんありまして
そういうのを
創って 世界に見せて
外人たちが真似をする
これ程気持ちいいことはですね
ないです
世界大会に
写真に写ってるように
これもフランスの
世界大会なんですけども
世界大会にそういう
自分で発明した技を持っていく
そして それをその場所できめる
これのですね 難しさっていうのは
本当に計り知れない
難しさでですね
毎日 毎日 練習して
練習して　練習して
100パーセント きまる技でも
本番では50パーセントになってたりとか
この写真はその新しい技が
決まった瞬間の写真
今年の５月なんですけども
やはり会場が
こういう風に盛り上がる
この瞬間が僕はやっぱりたまらなく
大好きです
時には失敗もするし
多々 今まで敗戦もしてきましたけども
この写真を見てもらって
分かる通り
これは実は僕が敗戦をした瞬間に
取られた写真なんですね
僕も自分では全然意識してないんで
大会終わった後に写真が上がってきて
やはり笑顔なんだな と
これはですね
僕の一つのスタイルというか
僕の中で決めていることであって
こういう世界大会に行って
ライディングをする 技をする
きまっても きまらなくても
そこに立つまでの期間 過程が
僕の中では一番大事
負けたら 負けたで
受け入れられるような
過去の練習を振り返って
自分を責めるポイントがないような
練習を重ねて 本番までに挑んでるんで
そうすることによって 負けた後
ライバルたちのですね
戦いを僕も
敗者としてですけども
応援することもできるし
そこでやっぱり
仲間との絆っていうのもね
すごく大事にしています
で 2008年
僕が初めて世界チャンピオンに
なったのが2008年 アメリカなんですけども
この時に初めて
気づいたことがあります
やはり あの
メジャースポーツと呼ばれる
野球 サッカー などと
僕らのエクストリームスポーツとか
呼ばれたりとか
アクションスポーツ
ストリートスポーツ
ファッションスポーツと
呼ばれることもあります
やはり全然業界が違いまして
世界チャンピオンになってから
初めて気づいたのは
ここからがスタートラインなんだ と
思いました
僕が世界チャンピオンに
なった瞬間を
どれだけの人が
日本人が見てくれてるかと言うと
ほとんどいません
BMX をやってる
業界の人たちだけです
で 僕はそこで初めて
BMX の世界チャンピオンになってから
ここから活動をすることによって
世界チャンピオンとして
メディアに出たり
イベントに出たり
ここからが始まりなんだな と
世界チャンピオンになって
もう一度世界チャンピオンになることが
絶対必要なんだな と思いました
世界チャンピオンという名で
注目を集めて
もう一回世界チャンピオンを獲る
二回目 獲った2012年
初めて2008年で獲った時よりも
すごく周りが
感動もしてくれましたし
たくさんの人が見てくれました
「ああ こういうことなんだな」と
その時初めて自分で思いまして
そこから
選手としての
BMX ライダーの内野洋平と
プラス
BMX を広めていく
内野洋平と
二つ 必要だということで
こうして今 こういう舞台にも立って
喋らせていただいてるのも
BMX ライダー
まあエクストリーム界の代表として
色んな方に
知っていただきたいな と思って
喋らせていただいてるんですけども
その中の活動の一つに
FLAT ARK という世界大会を
自分でオーガナイズしています
これはですね
去年初めてやったんですけど
去年初めてやったにも関わらず
世界のBMX ライダーたちが
一番素晴らしい大会だった
と言ってくれました
「それは なぜだと思いますか？」
っていう質問が去年あったんですけど
すごく簡単で
僕もこの大会に出てて
僕が創って
要するに自分が出たら
気持ちいい舞台を自分で作る
それだけ
世界大会
色んなフランス スペイン アメリカ
色んなとこに行って
「ああ この大会はすごくよかったな」
と思うところを盗んでですね
自分の大会に活かして
最高の舞台を作り上げた
これはそんなに
難しいことではなかったです
で こういうライダーと
もう一つの自分の活動という
今のエクストリームをやっている
スケートボード
インラインスケート
ダンスしかり
色々ありますけども
やはり みんな世界チャンピオンに
なりたいと強く願っています
しかし 世界チャンピオンになって
そこから やらないといけないこと
たくさんありまして
皆さんもご存知でしょうか？
オリンピック日本代表選手が
メダルをとる数と
エクストリームの日本代表が
メダルをとる数
たいしてね
差はないんです
やはりアメリカが強いとか
よく思われてるんですけども
日本がここ10年
メチャクチャ強いんです
ただ それを知らない方々が
日本にはたくさんいて
それは 誰のせいでもなく
僕たちの エクストリーマーの活動
やはりメジャーではない
っていうところから
そういうエクストリームの選手として
更にプロモーション活動として
これからの若い世代には
手本になるような
僕は活動をしたい と思ってます
「人の夢になることが僕の夢」
僕は常にそう思って活動しています
ありがとうございました
(拍手)